Друзі 1 +1 Ти не один знаєте що таке
Love Is Love is - це коли друг в СІЗО
замінити його на посаді заступника
голови комітету фінансового оце Справжня
дружба друзі Ви знаєте поки Ігорь
валерович сизо Коломойский але я бачу
что дело його живёт його питомци
продовжують посідати провідні місця А як
же без них це ж головне питання яке
сьогодні є верхов раді ні питання про
демобілізацію військових та ні нема на
це часу питання про повернення тридцятки
військовим друзі нема на це часу мінус20
на вулиці Хай сидять в траншеях а от
призначити нового заступника голови
фінансового комітету від групи 1+1 Як це
можна це ж просто якесь знаєте спадкове
місце групи 1+1 мати свого заступника в
цьому комітеті тому раз дубін
якось випав в СІЗО то тоді беремо
василевську смаглюк і її ставимо на це
місце Друзі Ну це ганьба ну Чим ви
займаєтесь і подивіться ви тому і не
хочете щоб Люди бачили що тут
відбувається тому ви ночами показуєте
Верховну Раду бо думаєте що це ну не
може хоч менше людей це побачать тому що
ви плювати хотіли на регламент тільки що
питання справа не в Мар'яні безуглій
Справа в тому є рішення комітету
нацбезпеки він щось пропонує давайте
розглядати Ні це нам не треба Але
питання призначити Ще свою людинку вже
призначили свою людинку на рахункову
тепер ще треба свою людинку призначити
на заступника голови фінансового
комітету ну це святе без цього ж ніяк це
головне питання в країні перший раз
зібралась Верховна Рада в цьому році
Подивіться якою ганьбою ви займаєтесь
Тому припиняйте все це не голосуйте
зараз за це рішення а виносьте питання
військових